david was saying from the studio that  you you really appreciate these end  games where it's balances between  offense and defense did you feel  comfortable going into that  yeah it was very difficult game actually  and  yeah i think that was worse at some  point  it was definitely easier for him to play  because of my wicking  on the other hand i had knight and so  and  when we got low on time knight should be  superior  in practical terms to bishop um  [Music]  yeah and i'm actually quite pleased with  my technique uh in a major piece of end  game and it's very it was very nice i  think so to summarize you you stare them  into your kind of territory  yeah kind of good luck to you in the  next game thanks